how everybody my name is markiplier or a
Wilford Worf thatched this knowing God
and honest you all think you know what's
best obviously who do not know what is
best
Wilfred war - nose was best this la
these are my letter of recommendation
for I am sick of serving you you want to
know why well why should I be your maid
when I'm more intelligent than you
largely okay I'm the maid nod master now
please don't get into the hole how can
you be so certain you are more
intelligent me eat animals and I don't
proof enough what you're just cuz you're
a vegetarian what how dare are you
I love me I love meat in my mouth I love
the way it explodes with juice in my
mouth I really really love meat and
everything about it I love meat all over
me I love de all kinds of meat
you know white meat a dark meat uh all
kinds of meat you know I love meat
why does these guys hate me Jesus just
stupid made me it's good for you does
the body good get it in your whatever
way you can whatever way you get that
meat in yeah it's okay with me jars just
stupid and ignorant huh yeah you never
do any work you're the laziest person I
ever met
bla bla bla bla bla bla enjoy the rush
your knife papi browning Ruby summers
Templeton what a stupid name booth now
just I'm thinking about meat everything
I really want some good meat right now I
could use some maybe a nice big sausage
that sounds pretty good no my mouth is
just watering at the thought of that
giant juicy sausage I can't wait for the
flavor to blow in my mouth exploded by
that way what am I thought about why how
everybody my name is markiplier or a
Wilfred Worf - I always liked the
original left4dead
hi
oh god I'm gonna I'm gonna try ah oh
let's eat oh look at him there's a
cupcake on his head sooo cute